so genau wurde noch nie eine chemische
reaktion beobachtet wissenschaftlicher
durchbruch chemische reaktion 300 mal
genauer analysiert mathematik in zwölf
millionen dimension jetzt den klicks zum
science fiction mathematischer
algorithmus liefert daten im
femtosekunden takt physikalische abläufe
die kernspaltung oder ähnliches
darzustellen oder zu messen stellt
heutzutage kein großes problem mehr
wie sieht es aber in der biologie oder
in der chemie aus können wir chemische
reaktionen vergleichbar gut analysieren
nein chemische reaktionen laufen in
teilweise einer einzigen femtosekunde ab
so schnell konnte man aber bisher keine
daten aufzeichnen oder überhaupt daten
aufzuzeichnen setzen wissenschaftler
röntgenlaser ein die bilder von der zu
beobachteten reaktionen machen da die
prozesse so schnell vonstatten gehen
können die daten zeitlich aber nicht
genau geordnet werden das heißt man weiß
nicht wann der leser die daten exakt
aufgezeichnet hat zitat alle uns bisher
bekannten experimentellen lösungen haben
es nicht geschafft eine zeit auflösung
von besser als etwa 14 5 sekunden zu
liefern so aber zur maz von der
university of wisconsin formats
bezeichnet den bis dato geltenden
wissenschaftlichen stand sogar als fluch
zitat die zeitliche unschärfe ist in
vielen bereichen der wissenschaft ein
flug bei einer solchen analyse entsteht
also also jede menge ungeordnet und
aufgrund der großen zeitlichen damals
unvollständiger datenmüll
mit der neuen methode seit dieser flucht
jedoch gebrochen ein mathematischer
algorithmus macht es ihnen jetzt möglich
daten einer chemischen oder biologischen
reaktionen in einem intervall von einer
fan pro sekunde aufzuzeichnen eine
femtosekunde das ist ein ziemlich kurzer
zeit abschnitt nämlich 000 000 000 000
000 1 sekunden genauso sagen also 15
stellen hinter dem komma centers für den
algorithmus trugen die forscher die
daten in ein modell ein das bis zu
12.000.000 dimensionen hat dann suchten
sie eine eindimensionale kurve auf der
alle daten punkte der aufgezeichneten
reaktion liegen gelingt ihnen dies
unterscheiden sich diese punkte nur noch
in
eine parameter der zeit und somit können
sie einen temporären also zeitlichen
ablauf der reaktion skizzieren im zuge
der im fachmagazin nature
veröffentlichten studie untersuchten sie
die dynamik von doppelt elektrisch
geladenen stickstoff molekülen und
konnten dabei wie es in der
pressemitteilung des deutschen
elektronen synchrotron heißt zitat das
dynamische verhalten der stickstoff
moleküle mit einer um den faktor 3 100
verbesserten präzision rekonstruieren
zitat ende
mit einer solchen sensationellen
präzision wäre es uns menschen dann auch
möglich die kleinsten enzyme reaktionen
der biologie mit hilfe der datenanalyse
von 12 millionen dimensionen zu erklärt
wie kann man sich zwölf millionen
dimensionen eigentlich vorstellen bisher
kennen wir abgesehen von der mathematik
nur unsere vier dimensionen also drei
raumdimensionen und eine dimension die
für die zeit verantwortlich
diese vier dimensionen können wir
halbwegs auch noch ganz gut verstehen
wie kommen forscher daraufhin zwölf
millionen dimensionen zu suchen einige
wissenschaftliche hinweise deuten darauf
hin dass es mehrere dimensionen geben
muss also mehr als unsere vier noch ein
paar modelle die von forschern
entwickelt wurden zum beispiel das
rendels an dem modell so richtig
vorstellen kann sich unser gehirn das
allerdings nicht warum aber denken wir
überhaupt und über höhere dimension nach
und geben uns nicht mit unserer vier
dimensionen zufrieden zuerst einmal ist
es gut dass wir uns mit gar nichts
zufrieden geben sondern immer weiter
forschen es gibt beispielsweise kräfte
die nur im zusammenhang mit mehreren
dimensionen sinn ergeben abgesehen davon
stellt sich noch die frage ob ein raum
ohne zeit möglich ist und umgekehrt
eigentlich nicht denn wenn wir den raum
erfahren möchten brauchen wir zeit und
umgekehrt brauchen wir natürlich auch
einen ort eine räumliche dimension in
der wehr die zeit erleben können und
dann kommen wir auch zum gleichen
ergebnis wie albert einstein mit seiner
relativitätstheorie was aus der
relativitätstheorie schlussendlich
geworden ist das könnt ihr euch hier
oben und ami nochmal ganz ausführlich
anschauen denn die in der theorie
beschriebenen gravitationswellen die
konnten ja vor kurzem direkt
nachgewiesen werden und jetzt noch eine
frage könnt ihr euch mehr als die
genannten vier dimensionen überhaupt
vorstellen
lasst uns mal über ein paar theorien in
den kommentaren diskutieren und sie
sammeln und wenn euch das video gefallen
hat dann würde ich mich über
einen daumen nach oben freuen und
natürlich wenn er ein kostenloses abo da
last und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran